c'est l'été de nos 20 ans rien de moins
alors on se permet un peu de nostalgie
et qui dit nostalgie estivale dit
souvent pops écoles alors on a fouillé
dans nos archers mais on s'y rendre
compte on avait fait de nombreux
reportages sur le sujet en 20 ans alors
pour le plaisir des petits des grands
des petits devenus grands voici les
meilleurs moments des reportages sur les
friandises glacées de 2002 à aujourd'hui
[Musique]
le psycho à presque 100 ans et il
continue de fasciner les enfants qui se
demande bien comment on les fabrique
c'est le cas de marc andré et roxanne
deux élèves de la région de rouyn
noranda en abitibi
alors je m'attaque centre-manche et je
sens que j'ai fait avec moi parce que
vous savez vous
ce que c'est je dis j
pour satisfaire leur curiosité
l'épicerie les a amenés à l' usine
dallaire spécialités qui fabrique entre
autres 150 millions de pops par année et
voilà c'est le saviez première étape
l'équipement entre haute et oblige
[Musique]
chiant de voir un peu la fabrication qui
coûtait à tous les sens de ceux qui
pensent que c'est une vérité étape
numéro 2 lavage des mains et c'est du
sérieux
[Musique]
ça prend environ combien de temps faire
un top 6 coeurs
c'est assez rapide sur vos produits à
saint-quentin où ça peut prendre jusqu'à
12 13 minutes avant que le pape soit
emballé tandis que d'alliés tourne pas
où ça peut prendre de 5 à 6 minutes puis
le tour est joué
[Musique]
un peuple c'est 80% d'eau le reste est
composé de solides sucre de canne et
sirop de maïs auquel on ajoute de
l'acide citrique pour son petit goût sûr
est un stabilisant aussi pour empêcher
le peuple de trop durcir et bien sûr les
différentes saveurs et colorants une
doseuses conduit le tout vers la ligne
de production et ses 425 moule moins de
dix minutes pour fabriquer un petit
plaisir de l'enfance que l'on retrouve
toujours avec bonheur à l'arrivée des
premiers rayons chauds
[Musique]
qui ne se souvient pas d'avoir mangé
l'époque seco
l'époque du bonheur pour cinq scènes et
la possibilité de développer son sens
artistique
[Musique]
ici à l'usiné les aliments lebel à la
chute on fabrique le pop classique comme
à l'époque
bashung cas c'est un produit leurs fans
on s'adresse à une clientèle
du ces merveilles ce jour sur les
produits qu'on fabrique alors moi cette
dimension là
aujourd'hui le classique parce que
partage sa place avec une panoplie de
produits comme sophie la pop une
friandise qu'on s'amuse appelé les
compagnies qui vont d'imagination pour
offrir des produits
colorés torsadé de toutes les formes de
toutes les couleurs comme ça qui est la
grosse mode cette année
les québécois en raffolent les dernières
statistiques montrent qu'on a dépensé en
une année plus de deux millions de
dollars en friandises glacées
on les classe en trois catégories
l'époque sa base d'eau sucrée les
peuples se fait à partir de juin et ce
avec des morceaux de fruits
une nouveauté les bonbons passe au
congélateur
[Applaudissements]
500 c'est comme ça que se voir classique
c'est vraiment bien lille à la baule et
[Rires]
les lives serveurs les gommes les
bonbons sûr et puis je jubile ya
beaucoup des produits du comptoir de
friandises que se retrouve maintenant
dans les produits glacés saha diversifie
l'offre mais pour ce qui est d'une
valeur nutritionnelle c'est vraiment une
gâterie points à l'aller
[Musique]
c'est quoi le pape se cure le plus
populaire mais ça ne se voit
ce soit n'importe quelle marque cette
catégorie produits là ces composés dont
dessus de colorants et de divers
additifs alimentaires y en a pas des
plus intéressants que d'autres qu'on
reste dans la catégorie des de supprimer
et visite de la gomme de guar la gomme
de carouge arômes artificiels colorants
cédé à gazon dont je connais pas le
monde c'est pas mon 5 je pense
la gomme de guar ou de caroube sont des
additifs alimentaires naturels ils
servent entre autres à donner une
texture moins dures sous la dent
écoutez calories selon le format cela
varie de 10 à 100 calories soit
l'équivalent de une à cinq cuillères à
thé de sucre
ce sont des gars afrique on a envie de
se payer durant l'été et c'est pas un
péché de le faire mais c'est peut-être
de faire attention à la quantité qu'on
consomme
[Musique]
ces enfants se régalent grâce au pop
classée de stephan brunel et lol
n'attend pas l'autre durant pas ma
famille automnal doit jeter non je suis
mis à faire des papiers gold plusieurs
façon bizarre sorte comment je le fais
avec du jus de l'ofc à l'idée est venue
ces jeux des fruits le dieu y aura tes
fans brunel est un fabricant de meubles
assez artisanal
installé au marché public depuis
maintenant sept ans cet accessoiriste de
médecine connaissez rien aux friandises
glacées quand il a commencé
c'est donc par essais et erreurs qu'il a
développé ses recettes
vous avez ferait aisément entre esch de
la manque des feuilles de menthe que je
crois que je mets dans mon mix qu'ici
j'ai annan au basilic j'aime anglais hop
hop hop au rabais que les frites
additionnel
mon nouveau pape sy col allan au basilic
le blanc d'oeuf ça fait gonfler la
matière ce qui rend le produit un peu
plus donc tuer
le monde
la science des pop score c'est une chose
très importante c'est la science qui
s'applique à tous ces les récents la
science de la cristallisation
quand vous avez un liquide et que vous
le refroidisse et ça va se cristalliser
et dans les pop s'y colle ce que vous
laissez vous voulez que bien sûr que ce
soit solide n'est pas trop solide parce
que s'ils voulaient pas sucé sur un bloc
de glace
ce qui est important c'est la taille des
cristaux plus les cristaux sont gros
plus ça va être dur retouché pluies vont
être petit plus ça va être agréable
il ya toutes sortes d'ingrédients qui
vont changer la cristallisation bien sûr
l'ingrédient principal c'est le sud vous
pouvez ajouter des fruits d'un genre de
purée les en fin de compte ça va
améliorer la texture savait faire que
les molécules d'eau elles vont pas
pouvoir se coller très proche qu'une
contrôle en fin de course à devenir
moins dur ça va être plus agréable au
goût j'ai jamais aimé les pacsés connaît
industrielle
de
yopougon que denis et moi qui avons
changé en vingt ans il ya des enfants
qui sont devenus durs à des intervenants
qui ont changé d'emploi des commerces
qui ont fermé et des gens qui nous ont
quittés c'est d'ailleurs le code du
fabricant de pops écoles au marché jean
talon qui est décédé l'an dernier mais
son fils milo poursuivre dignement la
tradition
[Musique]